welcome to this video against CD CD w
okay with one two three okay let's play
with quick I in this game last one was
really annoying to lose we're basically
only lost because of my bed time
management Wow to put the night who
takes with the night ah ok I wipe
removed f5 which is pretty ridiculous
against against the night capture okay
yeah it's still it's still playable at
least maybe you can take a five Bishop
takes Knight h4 now on this is another
one mmm this is surprising what is what
is the idea I mean hmm well this is idea
I don't get it right really like deform
I can't even go be five yet so
interesting g5g five h44 that's also
pretty good actually why not
not threatening f4 now ok f4 know G what
I mean you at one point you have to
react to what the other guys doing he
simply doesn't I'm just pushing my part
23 now isn't that strong I really hope
it is so let's stick here so what now
have to check he has to go King g2 after
that that looks like utter crap right is
a tack Reverend checked this just winch
York what a beard game now if I resign i
have two kings you 2nite edge forward
also winning it was really playing for a
loss from an earlier early stage show
okay well here here and f2 is just over
Queen f6 is also winning I guess check
but here I thought night eh for sure
jack should be made Queen yet remade
don't see what he's doing against that
and I can check desperado some stuff but
I mean it isn't be never reacted to my
moose I mean never here I mean here g5
and he white has to do something now he
cannot just allow everything here I
thought h4 maybe I would have planned
for this back and maybe 96 this is a bit
more interesting at least 96 and now
well BB 3 is just I don't know I don't
know the idea what you have to do
something about f4 that's a huge threat
because after F 113g form and f4 you
cannot take after night f4 Bishop f4
gear for that's a disaster so he has to
do something but you just played be
three
KF 4 and this is already close to win
but I think because I will threaten mg
for you also cannot really move that
night if you I mean what kind of
position is that check go with with all
kinds of things happening yet this is
just waiting for black chocolate Ord
winning check Neytiri resigned and you
have to really look at what the other
guys doing a little bit it tells helpful
to prevent a couple of threads at least
ok well thanks for watching